um yo dude call the Brants little uh you
know this man like pregnancy porn yeah
also first of all his haircut yeah he
actually looks like kind of normal now
yeah you know yeah before I just look
like him and his wife where this is the
same mm-hmm mmhmm yeah now he um he
definitely looks like her Christian good
Christian not exactly did that good way
read that captain yo this [ __ ] so I
posted a picture of her this man and he
goes his manager should have been like a
no I don't know if it's just a husband
thing or what but something about
Savannah being pregnant makes her so
smoking hot to me I'm gonna be a little
sad when she loses her belly what if we
just kept going I love nothing in
putting the baby the face Jesus man is
Christ yeah that's what that is that's a
fetish yeah that's a collab rant finally
learning about fetishes right there yeah
but like not realizing that they're a
thing yeah so just publicly saying it
yeah yeah that's that's I'm not really
sure what it is maybe he's just a
husband I'm kind of confused about like
I can't really [ __ ] turned on by
banning our toes but Havana's giant
pregnant stomach yeah and then [ __ ]
Kent bone replies yeah I love seeing
those beautiful human submarines that
[ __ ] is like Twitter account or like his
reddit account had a bunch of weird
comments like pregnancy porn ken bone is
the top comment on Cola branch [ __ ] I
agree yeah such a beautiful thing such a
beautiful item being created oh just
gets me [ __ ] hard I'm at such a
beautiful simple pure thing you know
life creating other life there's a small
human inside there and it just makes me
rock [ __ ] hard things that come to
mind me they're one [ __ ] a Christian
dude admitting fetishes like on very
public forum this is such a funny
his local church so just go ahead he's
like now I know sometimes we enjoy
watching interracial sex right yeah
everyone's like you guys we all enjoy
this right he's like too sheltered to
even know that it's like yeah what does
interests are you know everyone else we
all sometimes enjoy so when you guys
finger your buttons shower what do you
guys use cuz like the soap is really
[ __ ] with my pestle with my whole the
way so do you guys going dry or what's
the deal like what do you mean dude
when you finger your [ __ ] in the
shower and you're jacking off with the
gag ball in your mouth
guys stop I'm talking about when you
finger your ass in the shower it's a we
all do it why you looking at me like
that such a husband thing yeah exactly I
don't write you know when you're in the
shower and you put a little soap on and
you're like oh yeah
daddy's a bad boy uh-uh
you know you do that you do that what
like I'm crazy I'm talking about just
normal you just finger in your [ __ ]
your own [ __ ] in the shower and
you're you're calling yourself daddy's
little princess and you film it and you
upload it to your Dom cuz that's what
she wanted you to do you know and we do
that right yeah what's it so so in the
book of cheong yeah this is the Savannah
dude this your guys as wives get like a
little weird when they come home when
their clothes are kind of ripped cuz
you've been wearing them all day
Savannah's like been weird about it I'm
just I'm trying to tell her like but
like what else maybe this is a normal
thing
total husband thing spring on Savannah's
lipstick the other day just check out my
lips you know throw bra just put on
lipstick cuz tissue paper in there and
myself a sassy little queen yeah you
know we do this right you know it's like
a guy thing the husband just husband
things is just husband yeah it's the
hashtag just husband things yeah you
know right right boys no no we're
talking about dude that's your own I
mean that's fine that you like doing
that but that's that would be considered
probably like a fetish of some sort I
don't know whether is that a spice what
fetish was Fettuccine then spice
fettuccine that's when your fetishes
yeah that's all you wanna [ __ ] pasta
that's the word you use when you're
trying to ease your way into something
little fettuccine a little fettuccine
small fetish fettuccine a little finish
eating on that second thing that
reminded me of is I took this art art
class like I don't know second year of
college isn't we learned about like some
tribe where dude so they believed come
was like a holy like substance oh yeah
at least that's what the chief told
everybody okay so they believed in like
just the Chiefs comer I don't remember
that much I just know that come was very
like his yeah actually I think it was I
believe to be like from the gods okay so
like I was laughing cuz I'm like I
remember read like listening this
[ __ ] PowerPoint like crying laughing
I'm like bread this is just totally like
this dude figured it out no one else did
and it was like when a woman got
pregnant because like come could give
life it was seen that's why I was seen
as holy okay when a woman was pregnant
it was like the chief would try to [ __ ]
her as much as possible to like make the
baby like as healthy as possible so he
just could just keep just busting
Insider which is extremely graphic
that was his way of just getting to nail
everybody every pregnant J every
pregnant woman yeah yeah guys don't
bully call the brain he's a nice guy
yeah don't dumble him bully him but
don't yeah it's only bullying and we're
just funny it's hilarious to think about
someone that doesn't know what a fetish
is telling everybody you know it's like
the weird bathroom [ __ ] that you do that
that like it's a weird [ __ ] like if you
grow up I guess like that religious I
feel like you just don't talk about that
[ __ ] of course this is like a sin
yeah you can't talk about that [ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]